Liebe jede Winter unterwegs auf der
Suche nach dem ultimativen
poldererlebnis
[Musik]
die potenzielle
Konsequenz
[Musik]
meine Fresse sie planen
für mich momentan
[Musik]
sehr genau weiß
bewegen hat für die nächsten zwei Tage
[Musik]
die letzten Jahre haben wir immer mega
Gedanken geformt und Mini Risiko
Bereitschaft machen es bleibt einfach
[Musik]
geilste Gefühl und macht süchtig
unterschiedliche Jahr
spezialisiert
in Kontakt mit schlimmen Unfall Berg
mit tragischer Todesfall und da frage
ich mich schon
aus proofsmassage mit dem rastrisiko
Umbau wieso macht er das wieso setzt
[Musik]
natürlich bewusst dass man genau und
Abfahrten
[Musik]
und die potentielle gefordert diskutiert
absolut kein
bedenkenbild erkennt und so richtig
interpretieren und jede niedergruppe
muss es Lawine verschüttungssuche
sind die Grundvoraussetzungen nicht
verloren
machen
irgendwo genau
[Musik]
und wie fühlst du
in die Beurteilung
[Musik]
gestiegen die Temperatur ist nur eine
verzinkfaktoren beurteilt was macht der
Wind genau
[Musik]
und genau der Punkt fasziniert mich
potenziellenes Problem
irgendwo
[Musik]
so effizient wie möglich oder
und wenn ich alles sicherer
Mensch
ja ich meine wenn jetzt hier wirklich
eigentlich
ohne Probleme
[Musik]
e genau
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und genau hier sehen Sie
mit Sinne Videos in die ganze Welt
wie wichtig ist für dich Instagram ja
instagram ist einfach wichtig wurde
obwohl das ist teilweise gar nicht
stimmt
und ich finde es eigentlich falsch also
die schaffen genau
funktioniert ja
meine Moment
[Applaus]
das ist wichtig
[Musik]
ja
Galaxy
[Musik]
Schweiz
[Applaus]
umso wichtiger dass der SAM aus der
Firma macht die du sicher zu gestalten
für die aktuellen
genau wissen wie die Schneedecke
aufbautisch
8 mm kleine lamella wo war eigentlich
nichts schlimmes momentan nicht und es
geht nicht
zur nächsten Schicht ich kein großer
Unterschied oder wenn jetzt da ich
glaube
das Licht Problem
[Musik]
lawinentechnisch sind das mal gut die
News
auf der ganzen übertragen es ist sehr
gut möglich dass Lawinensituation
[Musik]
vielfach sehr sehr heftiger aber du
gesehen
machen und
also ich habe Momente erlaubt
es geht die Szenen
in quatschen
eigentlich
das ist so die slogisch überlege
zahlreich
[Musik]
bitteschön
soweit
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich bin ziemlich lange mit dem Business
3 und habe vielleicht sozusagen
das kann ich dir nicht beantworten
es ist wirklich schlussendlich ein
verantwortlich ich kann meine Sachen
machen aber ich zieldes
passiert ja klar ja oder wenn wir die
nächsten
das ist für dich klar nein das ist klar
dass das viel liegt die meine kein und
die Meinung die Lieder
große natürlich
Bruder
[Musik]
genau um das gottsmiral die pure und
intensive Momente
[Musik]
kontrollieren
das sind 300 Meter meine Fresse zwischen
zwei blecken
und da bin ich ja so im Denken sondern
Waschmaschine also ist wirklich
Waschmaschine und ich habe einfach nur
ein Sting an der letzte Felse haben
ohne ja genau und das sagt
und da bin ich schlussendlich bin ich
Zauber von der Lavin oh oder
das ist eigentlich mit dir bis wenn wenn
ein bisschen
Zeit wird das schwimme also einfach das
dass sie
der Geige kämpfen und nicht einfach
also blöder machen also du machst blöde
Entscheidung also da eine blöde total
also sozusagen
treffen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also
[Musik]
schlau
der erste Blick ist Gauloises
[Musik]
machen
eigentlich
keine Option
das ist für dich
für mich
zum Fahren aber es wird kein schöne
süße
ich wirklich
[Musik]
genau genau das sind wichtige Sachen
oder das ehrliche entscheidet der
schäufelt es bringt ja jetzt nichts dass
du mir hier bis zeigst okay genau
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich glaube entscheidet dass man ist
definitiv die richtige für mich ja ich
glaube für die ganze Gruppe
und das ist aber vielfach was für ein
obwohl das kein Sinn macht obwohl das
die Süßigkeiten
ehrliche Güte entscheidend
und wenn nichts du ein Frage hast Sam
oder mich du schrieb 40 Kommentar
vielleicht